على هذه الضربه الامريكيه البريطانيه
المشتركه ما طبيعه
الرد بالتاكيد ان العدوان الامريكي
البريطاني الذي بدا قبل ساعه تحديدا على
اليمن واستهدف عده مناطق في صنعاء
والحديده ومناطق اخرى سوف يكون له رد وهذا
جاء وعبر عنه الجانب اليمني بشكل رسمي
خلال الايام الماضيه و اكد السيد عبد
الملك بدر الدين الحوثي في خطاب عصر يوم
امس بان الجانب يمني لن يتردد في الرد على
اي اعتداء امريكي او بريطاني وبالفعل اذا
كان الامريكي او البريطاني يعتقد ان مجرد
شن ضربات خاطفه على المناطق اليمنيه وان
الامر سوف ينتهي فهو واهم الجانب اليمني
اكد مرارا وتكرارا انه لن يتردد في اتخاذ
الاجراءات العسكريه المناسبه للدفاع ضمن
الدفاع المشروع عن اليمن وضمن ايضا
التاكيد على موقف اليمن المؤيد للقضيه
الصينيه وما يتعلق بفرض منع الملاحه
الاسرائيليه في منطقه البحر الاحمر الجانب
الامريكي والبريطاني يتحملان كامل
المسؤوليه طيب العميد عبد الله بن عامر
نقطه مهمه وجب توضيحها ان امكن هل بدات
جماعه انصر الله الحوثيين بالرد فعلا مثل
ما جاء في تصريح علي القحوم ام تقول بان
الرد سيكون لا محاله بناء على التصريحات
السابقه ل القياديين في الجماعه بالتاكيد
الجانب اليمني عندما بدا العدوان هو تصدى
لهذا العدوان والمواجهات هي مفتوحه وقد
اختار الامريكي توقيتها والجانب اليمني
لديه من القدرات والامكانيات ما يجعله
قادرا على التصدي لهذا العدوان وعلى الرد
على ما حدث خلال الساعه الماضيه
باستهداف السفن الامريكيه في منطقه البحر
الاحمر او ما يسمى بمصادر التهديد نحن
نتحدث عن الدفاع المشروع عن النفس والجانب
اليمني اكد مرارا انه لم يتردد في استهداف
الجانب الامريكي والامر يعني لن يتوقف فقط
عند الضربات الخاطفه الامريكي متوهم
ويتوهم ان مجرد هذه الضربات سوف تمنع
اليمن او تؤدي الى ان يتراجع اليمن على
قرار منع الملاحه الاسرائيليه في منطقه
البحر الاحمر اليمن مستمر ولن يتردد في
هذا القرار وايضا قدرات ما يجعل الامريكي
ايضا يت رض للمزيد من الارباك في هذه
المنطقه لانه يتحمل مسؤوليه عسكره البحر
الاحمر وسبق وان حذر اليمن الجانب
الامريكي وايضا البريطاني بانه يدفع بهذه
المنطقه الى تصعيد خطير وهذا التصعيد قد
يؤدي الى التاثير السلبي على حركه الملاحه
العالميه في منطقه جنوب البحر الاحمر
وبالتاكيد ان الجانب الامريكي وايضا
البريطانيا يتحملان كامل المسؤوله عن ما
سيجري خلال الساعات وخلال الايام المقبله
في متابعه ذلك ومثل ما ما اشرنا فان
القيادي علي القحوم
وفي تغريده على منصه اكس ذكر بان الرد بدا
بالفعل لو نعود الى تلك الضربه الامريكيه
البريطانيه ما طبيعه المواقع التي
استهدفت طبعا تم استهداف عده مواقع عسكريه
في محيط العاصمه صنعاء وايضا في منطقه
الحديده او محافظه الحديده غربيه اليمن
وتحديدا المناطق الجنوبيه اضا الى مناطق
اخرى وحتى هذه اللحظه هذه معلومات اوليه
وخلال الساعات المقبله سيتم رصد وتقييم
الاضرار والاعلان عنها عنها بشكل رسمي
العدوان الامريكي على ما يبدو حتى هذه
اللحظه ان استخدم القصف من خلال البوارج
الحربيه على محيط العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء
وايضا على مناطق اخرى لاننا لم نرصد حتى
هذه اللحظه وتحديدا في محيط صنعاء اي تحلق
للطيران الحربي الاجنبي
وال الساعات المقبله سوف تكشف المزيد من
التفاصيل حول طبيعه هذا العدوان وايضا حول
حقيقه او طبيعه الرد اليمني على هذا
العدوان الذي كان متوقعا واليمن اكد انه
سوف يرد على هذا العدوان وسوف يستمر في
موقفه المتضامن مع القضيه الفلسطينيه وحتى
وقف العدوان على غزه وحتى يرفع الحصار على
غزه هذا الموقف مبدئي وموقف ثابت لا يخضع
للمساومه ولا يخضع للمزايده